hey reject nation do you guys like
Jessica Jones well we're gonna watch
episode 4 on patreon but Marvel
Entertainment uploaded I want you to
cray-cray Patsey right now I'm pretty
sure killgrave sang this song little cry
cry like a little bit of it or something
in season 1 oh boy maybe he'll be a
feature on this track or did I see like
some clip of it I don't know I've some
like thing of like killgrave in my mind
seen a part of the song anywho let's
let's check it out everyone loves Trish
Walker very according to a recent love
the latest season has been getting
definitely one of highlights
[Music]
trekker a it's like for crazy
[Laughter]
and all the backup dancers provides it
along whether crayfish
Oh
yeah
Courtney's part of the Marvel Canon now
she's gonna have her own movie where I'm
Hospital ittsan heading
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
if you're gonna throw in the Jessica
Jones logo they should have done
something with Jessica at the end like
watching this video yeah I'm like [ __ ]
or something like yeah yeah you know
it's just an amusing little video that
they made although I guess for what this
is I sort of wish that they really threw
down on a wacky song because she just
repeats the same line over no yeah it
seems like they shot a very basic video
which I guess for the time when Patsy
was a thing maybe it would have been a
basic video you know they did that
guardians of the galaxy one really went
like full bonkers for that one which I
loved
yeah and that had like a bunch of
personality and it had a bunch of it
like it was a written out song at least
yeah yeah yeah this is just repetition
and I get the intention is to be like
cringe-worthy but it seems like they
just shot some basic [ __ ] and then they
had some like comedy writers come
onboard and improvise bubbles to put on
the screen the bubbles don't seem like
they were actually scripted for the
video it seems like they shot a video
and then they were like what could we
throw here eat something else yeah there
are plenty of talented you know female
comedy musicians out there who could
have punched this up really hard you
know do some kind of like female Marvel
tinged Lonely Island video basically you
know what I would have liked to have
seen like this is why Patsy was so huge
yeah as opposed to this woman would have
never made it yeah this is this kind of
when in my mind and it's it's currently
leaving it it's like it's the same line
over and over again the dance
choreography is nothing it's very basic
yeah it's like incredibly basic that
maybe that's the point but why why why
do that for this one do something more
fun and lively and bland yeah
bland cringe you know it's an oculus
maybe at best it's funny ish if you know
some of those characters but yeah I know
yeah I'm just trying to find nice things
and it also seems weird to actually kind
of promote Jessica Jones season two it's
like what have you've never seen Jessica
Jones and this is the first thing you
watch yeah and then for some reason
you're kind of compelled to go watch
Jessica Jones after this and there you
go
Jessica Jones a is not really fully
about Trish be the tone is just so not
snappy and gravity enough to make me
want to watch whatever words I because
the Guardians one fits for guardians
yeah and the style and it's doing so
many things and you know that didn't
look overly expensive ultimately but you
know you're like oh at least you're
doing a lot this is sort of like a
halfway for me I like I appreciate the
idea and I think I you had it best words
like this could have worked if they
punched up the video and then put a
button on the end with Jessica that
reestablishes you know at least the tone
of the show a little bit you know that
touches on it yeah something like [ __ ]
somebody a little a knock you like her
and I'm just watching the video like
that would have been fun or Jessica like
uploading it just you know to mess with
or something you know yeah any anything
to give this a distinct flavor that
makes sense why it would be related back
to Jessica Jones beyond just oh yeah
this is one of their characters well you
know what though when I really think
about it I think this expands the Marvel
Canon hey we're gonna get Courtney
Courtney spinoff soon new chick who
acknowledged by Marvel in this video so
I bet she was a background dancer for
this video and then the writers of the
bubbles thought who's in the shots a
little more yeah and then in season 3
just all the scenes between Trish and
her mom are only gonna be them arguing
about that one guy yeah did you guys
love it do you guys love that video what
do you prefer Jessica Jones season 2 or
the I want your cray-cray
full music video debate about it in the
comments subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification now check us out
on page
we're we're watching Jessica Jones
pretty much one Episode a week right now
like 3/4 living epic hop we offer around
between six main shows get bring it down
you